>> WHAT HAPPENS WHEN DEMOCRATS
ARE IN CHARGE?
SOMETIMES THEY GROW UP.
>> ILLEGAL ALIENS SHOULD NOT BE
TREATED THE SAME AS PEOPLE WHO
ENTER THE U.S. LEGALLY.
>> I VOTED NUMEROUS TIMES WHEN I
WAS A SENATOR TO SPEND MONEY TO
BUILD A BARRIER TO TRY TO
PREVENT ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS FROM
COMING IN.
>> WE SIMPLY CANNOT ALLOW PEOPLE
TO POUR INTO THE UNITED STATES
UNDETECTED, UNDOCUMENTED,
UNCHECKED.
>> Greg: WOW.
WHO ARE THESE BIGOTS AND WHERE
THEY SAW HIM INTO ILLEGAL
IMMIGRANTS.
ACTUALLY, THEY WERE BEING
ADULTS, BECAUSE THEY WERE IN
CHARGE ONCE.
NOW NO LONGER IN POWER, THEY
DEPEND ON THE REPUBLICANS TO
PLAY GROWN-UP AND THEY BE THE
CASE AS THOUSANDS OF MIGRANTS
COME OUR WAY.
FACT IS, THEY NEED REPUBLICANS
TO BE THE BAD GUYS, I.E., THE
ADULTS, SO THEY TAKE STANCES
THEY DON'T EVEN LIKE.
WE'VE BEEN WATCHING THEM OFF OR
EMOTIONALLY LOPSIDED VIEWS THAN
THEY CLEAR YOU AND ME FOR
BRINGING UP CONSEQUENCES.
BUT IMAGINE IF THERE WERE NO
BORDER CONSTRAINTS TO STOP THE
CARAVAN.
IMAGINE IF WE JUST HOMED JOHN
LENNON SONGS AS WE WAVED
EVERYONE THROUGH.
OF COURSE, YOU WOULD ONLY LAUNCH
A DOZEN NEW CARAVANS, EACH
FILLED WITH KNOWNS AND UNKNOWNS.
IT'S OBVIOUS.
WAIT, THAT'S ALREADY HAPPENING.
THAT'S A CONSEQUENCE.
WHY AREN'T THE DEMOCRATS
WORRIED?
BECAUSE THEY KNOW THE
REPUBLICANS IN THE U.S. BORDER
PATROL WILL END UP BEING THE BAD
GUYS.
WE ALWAYS ARE.
AND BAIL THEM OUT.
IT'S PERFECT FOR DEMOCRATS
BECAUSE REALLY, IT'S ALL ABOUT
FEELING GOOD.
IT'S ALL THEATER, AND THE EVIL
CHARACTERS OR ANYONE WHO THINKS
CRITICALLY, AND A HERO, THE
PROGRESSIVE WHO PUSHES EMOTION
WITHOUT CONSEQUENCE, AND HE WINS
BECAUSE HE CAN FAKE EMPATHY,
STILL HAVE A BORDER, AND A
VILLAIN TO BLAME IT ON.
IT'S GREAT BEING A KID.
YOU CAN DEMAND THE DUMBEST
THINGS AND SECRETLY HOPE YOUR
PARENTS AREN'T LISTENING.
WHAT DO YOU THINK OF MY THEORY,
DANA, THAT THE DEMOCRATS NEED
REPUBLICANS TO BE THE BAD GUYS
BECAUSE THEY KNOW THAT THEY ARE
GOING TO PULL THE BAND-AID OFF,
THEY ARE GOING TO GROUND THE
STUDENTS, YOU KNOW WHAT I MEAN?
>> Dana: I WAS THINKING ABOUT
A BLIND TASTE TEST, JUST TO
COMMENTS FROM REPUBLICANS AND
DEMOCRATS WHEN THEY WERE IN
CHARGE AND THEN REPUBLICANS AND
THE GEORGE BUSH TERM, THEN
PRESIDENT OBAMA.
BLIND TEST.
READ THEM.
I THINK IT WOULD BE HARD-PRESSED
TO FIND ANY DISAGREEMENT.
THAT IS WHAT IS SO FRUSTRATING
ABOUT THIS ISSUE.
>> Greg: MY THEORY, EMILY,
WHEN YOU ARE OUT OF POWER, YOU
CAN SAY THINGS YOU REALLY DON'T
MEAN, THEN YOU GET INTO POWER,
SUDDENLY YOU GROW UP AND GO,
WELL, YOU'VE GOT TO HAVE A
BORDER.
>> Emily: ABSOLUTELY.
JUST TO BUILD ON WHAT YOU SAID
IN YOUR OPENING, I THINK THAT
THE LESS FRAMED, THE COVERAGE
AND CONVERSATION, EITHER IT IS
EMOTIONAL AND MORAL OR YOU ARE
TOTALLY DEVOID OF COMPASSION.
AND YOU CAN'T HAVE BOTH.
THE IRONY TO ME IS THE FACT THAT
THAT ALL     ALL-OR-NOTHING APPO
THAT ALL     ALL-OR-NOTHING APPC
THAT ALL     ALL-OR-NOTHING APPH
DOES A DISTURBANCE IN THAT
COMPASSION ARENA TO ALL OF THE P
COMPASSION ARENA TO ALL OF THE O
COMPASSION ARENA TO ALL OF THE L
COMPASSION ARENA TO ALL OF THE ,
COMPASSION ARENA TO ALL OF THE T
COMPASSION ARENA TO ALL OF THE E
COMPASSION ARENA TO ALL OF THE M
COMPASSION ARENA TO ALL OF THE G
COMPASSION ARENA TO ALL OF THE A
COMPASSION ARENA TO ALL OF THE T
COMPASSION ARENA TO ALL OF THE S
INCLUDED, AND ALL THE CENTRAL
AMERICAN AND SOME SOUTHERN
AMERICAN COUNTRIES THAT ARE
AFFECTED IN A MULTITUDE OF
AREAS, ECONOMICALLY AND
POLITICALLY AND CRIMINALLY.
THERE ARE SO MANY OTHER ISSUES
THAT I WOULD THINK IT WOULD BE
THE GREATER HUMANITARIAN AND
COMPASSIONATE POSITION TO BE
HONEST AND COMPLEX ABOUT THAT
COVERAGE AND CONVERSATION.
>> Greg: JESSE, I THINK THERE
IS A LOT OF DISHONESTY AND
PUSHING AN EVENT THAT HAS NO
POSITIVE OUTCOME FOR THE PEOPLE
INVOLVED.
SOONER OR LATER THEY'RE GOING TO
HIT SOMETHING THAT ISN'T GOING
TO LET THEM IN.
EVERYBODY ELSE CAN WALK AWAY AND
DO ANOTHER STORY.
THIS STORY MAY BE OVER IN A
COUPLE OF DAYS, BUT YOU KNOW IT?
WE HAVE INCITED A COUPLE OF
CARAVANS AND THEY ARE GOING TO
FAIL AT SOME POINT.
>> Jesse: THEY ARE, AND I'M
THE MOST COMPASSIONATE GUY AT
THIS TABLE.
>> Greg: I BELIEVE THAT.
AT LEAST THE TOP FIVE.
>> Jesse: YET I'M PORTRAYED AS
MEAN-SPIRITED BECAUSE I WANT TO
MAINTAIN THE TERRITORIAL
INTEGRITY AND SOVEREIGNTY OF THE
UNITED STATES AND COUNTRY THAT I
LOVE.
I TREAT THIS COUNTRY LIKE A
HOUSE.
I WANT TO KNOW WHO IS COMING IN,
AND I WANT TO INVITE THEM WHEN
THEY COME IN, AND I THINK EVERY
AMERICAN AGREES WITH ME.
AND I WANT HUNGRY FOREIGNERS TO
COME TO AMERICA AND MAKE MONEY
AND ACHIEVE SUCCESS, BUT I ALSO
DON'T LIKE FOREIGNERS
CONTROLLING U.S. IMMIGRATION
POLICY.
I'D LIKE AMERICANS TO CONTROL
U.S. IMMIGRATION POLICY.
SO WHEN YOU SEE A BUNCH OF
IMPOVERISHED STRANGERS FROM
CENTRAL AMERICA KIND OF
HOSTILITY RUSHING NORTH, AND
THEY ARE CHANTING THINGS ABOUT
OUR PRESIDENT AND WEARING
T-SHIRTS THAT KIND OF ARE A
LITTLE DEFENSIVE AND THEY ARE
PAYING COYOTES CASH AND WHEN
THEY MEET UP WITH A BUNCH OF
LAWYERS FROM THE ACLU SOUTH OF
THE BORDER AND THEY ARE COACHED
ON WHAT TO SAY IN ORDER TO GET,
A LOT OF AMERICANS LOOK AT THAT
AND ARE A LITTLE UNEASY ON THAT.
ALL WE ARE SAYING IS, DON'T CUT
IN LINE.
COME HERE IN AN ORDERLY PROCESS.
WE WANT A FAIR AND ORDERLY
IMMIGRATION SYSTEM.
BUT WE ALSO WANT COMPASSION FOR
AMERICANS.
YUMA AND, I THINK, ARIZONA,
BEING OVERWHELMED BY IMMIGRANTS
WHO ARE JUST DUMB TO BARBECUE
BORDER PATROL BECAUSE THEY CAN'T
HOLD THEM.
THE TOWNSPEOPLE OF YUMA ARE
FEELING LIKE, WHAT IS HAPPENING
TO OUR TOWN?
WE DIDN'T VOTE FOR THIS, WHERE
IS THE COMPASSION FOR THEM?
>> Greg: JUAN, A SECOND
CARAVAN STARTING, OBVIOUSLY
THEY'RE GETTING ENCOURAGEMENT BY
SEEING THIS ONE, THEN THEY START
ANOTHER, SO THAT IS THE
CONSEQUENCE OF THIS.
>> Juan: I THINK IT IS THE
CONSEQUENCE OF THE FAILURE OF
THIS PRESIDENT TO ENACT ANY KIND
OF IMMIGRATION POLICY.
OBVIOUSLY THE HORRIBLE THINGS HE
WAS DOING TO CHILDREN AT THE
BORDER HAS NOT ACTED AS A
DISINCENTIVE.
IN FACT, NOW WE SEE INSTANCES
LIKE -- I WANTED TO SAY TO YOU,
GREG, THAT TO ME, I WAS THINKING
TO MYSELF, WOW, SO I GUESS THE
DEMOCRATS CLEARLY ARE NOT PEOPLE
WHO ARE OPPOSED TO BORDERS OR
OPPOSED TO KEEPING ILLEGALS OUT.
WHAT WE SAW AT THE TOP OF THIS
SEGMENT WAS DEMOCRATS SAYING, WE
NEED BORDERS, WE NEED LEGITIMATE
PROTECTION, BUT MAYBE WE DON'T
NEED A WALL THAT'S NOT GOING TO
BE EFFECTIVE.
BUT THE SECOND THING TO SAY HERE
IS THAT, AGAIN, YOU DEMONIZE
PEOPLE, AND TODAY, RIGHT-WING
MEDIA FIGHTS WERE SHOWING A
PICTURE OF WHAT LOOKED LIKE A
BEATEN MEXICAN COP, THE PICTURE
WAS FROM 2012.
>> Greg: I DIDN'T DEMONIZE
ANYBODY, JUAN.
>> Juan: IT RATHER THAN SAYING
THAT WE HAVE HUMANITARIAN CRISIS
RIGHT NOW AND THAT WE NEED TO HE
RIGHT NOW AND THAT WE NEED TO HP
PEOPLE AND DEAL WITH THIS CRISIS
SO THAT WE DON'T HAVE NEW LINES
FORMING, INSTEAD, THE OAKLEY
EMPHASIS IS ON, OH, THE
DEMOCRATS ARE ON THE BAD ONE.
I WISH REPUBLICANS WOULD SAY,
YOU KNOW WHAT, I UNDERSTAND,
THAT SOMEBODY IS PUSHING A FAIR
BUTTON, AND IT'S THE KIND OF
THING THAT THEN LEADS PEOPLE TO
CONCLUDE, OH, WE SHOULD GO AFTER
THE DEMOCRATS.
>> Greg: >> Emily: , JUAN,
I THINK IT'S UNFAIR TO SAY THAT
THEY DON'T WANT TO CHANGE THE
PROBLEM.
THEY HAVE TRIED TO CHANGE, AND
WHEN YOU SAY THAT THE BALL WON'T
WORK, I DISAGREE WITH YOU.
DEMOCRATS DON'T WANT THE BALL
BECAUSE THEY KNOW IT WILL WORK.
>> Juan: IT WON'T WORK.
>> Greg: IF I WANTED TO GROW
WHY WON'T IT WORK?
>> Juan: I'LL TELL YOU
QUICKLY.
MOST PEOPLE THAT COME INTO THIS
COUNTRY, AND OVERSTAY VISAS,
THEY COME ON AIRPLANES -- COATS
SPEWING THE WALL WON'T PREVENT
PEOPLE FROM COMING OVER ON AN